years ago
we find in our heart of the
building meals at the foot of the lantern
linked to major volumes of the
whole project and which contains the
main meeting rooms
the functions which were to be at the
different levels with sizes of
increasing proportion and  then
reducing
this lantern has a narrow base
not only because it stuck well
but above all because it was
unthinkable to put a support beyond this
limit to say that there is under this
building a large February tunnel and which
comes close to the name of blue links at the meeting
[Music]
all the texts recession sculptor
africa
[Music]
we are here in the old part
of europe a building this
is the part that was called the
residence palace and you see here
the  he old corridor which is also
listed as the facade of the
building
this mauritius party in this palace was
built in the 1900s and 20s
and the aim was to make a
luxury building with  ec the apartments restaurant
here this beat to no longer some
success at the beginning but towards the end of
the 1930s the building was half
empty
then during two world wars
sellert minister assures the world who
settled and after the war c  t is
the building administration and the Ministry
of National Building Education was
quickly from about 2002 from
2004 we started looking for
land to set up the
European Council in Brussels
and finally since the
palace residence was quickly  available located
next to justus lipsius next to the ex in
force of the berlaymont
but everyone
thought it was a very good idea it was a big challenge for
the architect to have a
harmonious whole of the old and the new and
he  opted for the contrast you see
if the corridors are square and which
in tempered colors while the
modern part is very lively
with cheerful colors
so it forms a huge contrast
that's what  ui makes the building interesting in
are
if I chose the wind it is by sanou
control of squares and to go to the
elementary forms squares rectangles and
colors in a very
particular alchemy but which has as objective to
create joy and  the trigger
we wanted to use a range of
natural materials is limited a lot
of wood and one wood the oak is the
only box referred to here and then the glass
which here is extra clear which gives the
two lanterns what you are white 3
also we carry out steel in the
building in particular to try our
faithful ones
we first had a campaign of
asbestos removal
then a campaign of demolition and
consolidation and it is only at this moment
that we could start  to build the
lantern and once the lantern was
built floor by floor
when all this metal mechanics was
finished so at that time we were able to
build the two facades which close the
glass cube
[Music]
the very visible and obviously element  ent
the outer envelop composed of the uja
chain sites already recovering from the
demolition of the lombardy tower is
not a building stand there or not
it can work only in
combination with the us rictus lists
next they are communicating vessels
people are either in one or
the other building and a connection
easy circulation at all times
was also part of the
complexity and the great challenge of this project
[Music]
in terms of respect for the  environment
there is first of all the energy balance of
buildings in this concern gives
and thermal insulation at
appropriate solar protection ratings while being
able to benefit from solar
gains when they are useful for mi vé when
it freezes and which is a  good sunshine
let's take this energy
[Music]
the council now has three buildings
lined up in the street of the law the
oldest the justice lipsius then the
last the europe a building and the eulex
[Music]